David, thank you for joining me
and giving me your time.
Thank you, Michael.
Nice to meet you.
How are you doing?
So you're talking to me
from Dallas?
From Austin, actually, right
Yes. Correct. How are you?
And you just moved here --
you moved there
before the corona started?
Actually, in between.
I had the last flight from Israel
to United States.
The last one?
The last one, Delta flight, yes.
Wow! Okay.
It's a good thing, you got the last one.
How is it over there right now?
Is it crazy?
It depends.
Everything is compelled.
We have some friends in New York
and they suffered really hard.
- Oh, yeah.
- And compared to them, we are  in a
pretty good situation right now.
Definitely. Okay.
So the most important thing
to know is that I'm speaking here
to an optimist, which is great.
I love that, and you consider
yourself  well-versed
in what it means
to bring happiness
to consumers.
That's my little dog here, Benny,
who might make an appearance.
So we'll just let him
set aside for a little bit
before he gets us into trouble
I'd love to sort of walk through
a little bit about your history
your background, and how you got
excited about this topic.
I would love to talk to you
also a little bit about on
what it means to have a startup --
You're the CTO of a startup
in the travel space --
marketplace in the travel space,
and it's pretty challenging times
for these sorts of companies now.
So maybe you can touch on that
a little at the end.
- Sure.
- So let's just get started.
Tell me a little bit
about yourself.
My name is David.
I was born in Russia.
We just moved to Israel
when I was 12.
Since 2016, I worked a lot
with glass companies.
I actually started my career
at a company called NDS.
I build various security solutions
for digital TV,
more like projects for DIRECTV,
BSkyB, and some other big
corporate clients.
I moved to my own business,
my own startups in 2010.
Since that period,
I had an experience working on
different products
from financial industry,
advertising, et cetera.
I was part of
NFX Guild accelerator
in Palo Alto
four years ago, actually.
Was co-founder
of Free Startups Board,
with  many different
other startups
as well as Fortune 500 companies.
I joined Stride a year ago,
a bit more than a year ago.
Right now, we are
in a pretty interesting
and challenging times.
Yeah.
But we do believe
that we will create
a serious impact for
people when all this madness,
over and --
Definitely.
People will --
definitely want to go
to some great Safari tours
or some interesting experience
in Himalayas
or some amazing tours
that they are like dreaming
right now all the time.
And we will help them
to make it real soon.
As a company?
Yes.
Oh, wonderful, wonderful!
That's amazing. I actually did --
I did a --
I went to Kilimanjaro
a few months ago with my family
as well as the Safari,
and it was one of the most
extraordinary experiences
that I've ever had.
Tell me a little bit
about yourself and why
you consider yourself an optimist
and what makes you take about
bringing happiness to consumers?
I work a lot on B to B projects
and different projects
that didn't make me feel --
they help me to
get pretty good money on one side
and I also invest it in some other
startup as well, but it's not
something that creates meaning
in your life and it doesn't
provide any serious value
if you really want to move forward
to build something that, actually,
you want to wake up for
and move yourself over.
When I was a kid, I asked
my mother what does it mean
being happy.
And I got the following answer
from her, "When you wake up early
in the morning, you are happy
to go to work and in the evening,
you're happy to go home."
This was her definition
of happiness.
I try to define it myself.
I'm probably still working
on this and my wife always
joking at me like,
"Are you talking about happiness?
You're still struggling to define it
for yourself.
How can you actually provide
happiness to others?"
So try to, first of all,
find it in yourself
and this kind of [unclear 07:03.8]
I actually recommend
to all other people―
entrepreneurs and just people
who want to work
in a great environment.
- Yeah.
- First of all,
starting from your own
personal life.
Define what does it mean
happiness for yourself.
- Is it --
- Sure.
really something that
matters to you at all?
Can you take it from there?
Just an example on myself,
like what does it mean
I have been happy
for myself, right?
So spending time
with people I like
and people I love.
My family, for example.
I do like helping other as well.
I highly believe in solidarity
and it's a great example right now
in those crazy times that people
share some food that
they bought and some masks
and helping each other.
It's something that make
a huge impact.
And on a personal level,
integrity is something
that's really important as well.
Those are my points, my matters.
When you go to your job,
for example,
what matters to you, like --
what kind of people
you would like to work with?
I can give an example.
I personally like working
with people who are doers,
who are actually --
can deliver something.
I do want to be
in a supporting environment,
people who help each other
and don't blame each other
like, "This is your fault,"
and et cetera, et cetera.
It's really important that people
respect each other as well.
It's critical to have
really great relationships
in the company as well.
And the entrepreneur mindset,
it's something that
also makes me happy.
And when we are moving
the same pattern to product,
what do you like
about your product?
or like a --
- Right.
- great user experience, right?
You do want that the product
you are using or making
share some common values with you.
The product must be aligned with
your values that you believe in.
And if it's something that
you don't believe,
you will never use it, right?
Right.
On another part,
when you build a product,
you want real to fans.
And when you make
like a significant impact,
you will have those fans
and they have some feelings
about your products.
And let's say,
you release something
they didn't like, they respond.
"Listen, we didn't like this,
and we didn't like that,
but we really want this back,"
and so on.
They will try to convince you
that this type of product needs
to be updated or changed,
and so on.
The worst part for any product
is people who don't really
care about it at all, like,
"This product is
indifferent to me," like
"Today, you are a hero,
that's fine.
We are fighting on
just the price and that's it.
And tomorrow,
someone else will just
improve their supply chain
and reduce some pricing cost and --"
There is no product at all like --
And your company just goes away.
Right.
Those kind of things
that really matter,
I highly recommend for any person
who is involved in product
building, product definition,
first of all, start from your life.
Move to your work definition
and then, move to product.
And by this, you can actually
define all of the process yourself.
No, that makes a lot of sense.
I do agree on
a lot of points here.
I think this idea of resilience
and what allows you to
to keep going and even when
the going gets tough,
and you know,
having those users aligned
with your core values.
And when your product
shares those core values,
then the users are not just
buying your product,
but they're, all of a sudden,
becoming champions of it,
and they feel personally
attached to it.
Actually,
I did a little bit
of research before
and I think you have
a pretty interesting story
of a bicycle accident, right?
Did I see correct?
Yeah.
You broke both your hands
and you managed to still do
something interesting
while breaking both of your hands.
Yeah, it's a long story about that.
I had some accident
and I was in some
like crazy situation
seven, eight years ago, actually.
Yeah. I had to recover
myself personally,
financially, and just everywhere.
And it was a very
challenging situation.
One person that probably
really helped me to move over
this situation was my wife,
and she actually helped me,
and she was extremely supportive
beyond this period of time.
And you always need this person.
Some other people that I got all
the inspiration from,
more people that were around me.
They actually helped
me to move forward,
and it's pretty
important situation.
- And the --
- And that you actually --
during that time,
you learned Ruby on Rails, right?
Not exactly.
I actually had previously
experienced using Ruby on Rails.
I think it was version 1.8
at the NDS, that time.
And I started checking
what's going on
in the market right now?
Where can I go next?
Like what should I do?
I had like a very serious
bicycle accident.
I should move over.
I wasn't able really to write
a code at that time
because I was fully disabled.
And I said, "Okay."
I know that Ruby on Rails
has like a very serious impact
on many startups at the time.
Right.
And Basecamp was developed
during this period
and some other great startups.
And I said like,
"I have to move this software."
This software actually helps
a lot of developers
just to build great stuff,
and I can move forward.
I started learning just by doing.
At the same time,
the demand just became very high
and I started helping
other startups
and move forward
from this period. Yeah.
And so, you became a consultant
on Ruby on Rails?
I also did some consulting,
not only for startups
but I worked with a company
like Conduit and some other
big companies as well.
I worked with Gartner in New York
and Whitewater Cooper House
in San Francisco,
- and it's cool.
- Sure.
So I actually had startup
experience as well as
Fortune 500 as well.
So tell me a little bit about
Stride and what are
some of the core values
that you have over there
that are aligned with yours
that bring happiness to users?
First of all,
being in travel industry
is great thing to deal with,
right?
it's something that --
you always like to travel
unless you prefer sitting
on your couch and just --
Yeah.
watch TV or Netflix,
or whatever.
But most people do like
travelling, especially,
in those crazy times.
So I am very aligned
with the major goal
helping people to find exactly
where they can go right now,
what type of experience
they can get in various places
around the world,
not only just on the next street
or just around you but all over.
-- Yeah.
-- And this is something that we
are trying to achieve
by helping people
to move all around,
get to know many different jobs
around the world,
and move forward.
And this is probably
the most interesting part
in Stride that we are
working on right now.
And so, what is it like
being a CTO
of an upcoming startup,
and all of a sudden,
corona breaks out?
Good question.
It's charged on --
Listen, there are
always ups and downs,
and it highly depends
if you have enough time
with your cash
on a personal level,
as well as on the company level.
Yeah.
Sometimes, you have to make
immediate decisions
like some people
you have to lay out or fire,
or just pull some projects,
specifically concentrate
on cash.
It's probably the
most important one.
Measure everything
you're doing many times a day
starting from planning.
Is the thing that you are working
right now
really matters to you
and to your customers?
Will this something
that will make a change
in the upcoming months?
How people actually going to
spend their time on travel
after the coronavirus pass?
Will they actually travel abroad
or they try to stay around?
So there are a lot of questions
that we are trying to
answer right now.
And I assume that nobody
actually knows the true answer.
Definitely. Right.
But we will see.
It's an interesting time.
It's an interesting challenge.
And we're here to make it work.
I'm optimistic by my nature,
because being pessimistic
doesn't provide any value.
And you need some personal
balance in your life
just to move forward.
- Right.
- And it's something that
pretty important.
How important is it
do you think to be an optimist
in a leadership team, whether
it's a startup or a big company
rather than being the pessimist
or the realist that is always
trying to give
the bad side to things?
Because there are balancing
personalities that I would find
useful also in our leadership team.
All right.
Sometimes,
you see being too optimistic
is not always good,
like you're trying to oversell
yourself too much.
You're trying to bring too much
promises without actually
providing any value,
and it's not good.
At some point,
it just creates a negative impact.
On the other side,
you always should be
more optimistic than
realist or pessimist,
I don't know,
and be prepared because --
the future is bright and we
want to go to something happy,
and dealing with something
that doesn't really matter at all.
It doesn't provide any motivation.
Right.
These are [unclear 18:33.3]
to your team
and it doesn't provide
like any serious value.
- I think
- Right.
every entrepreneur
must be optimistic
in some way; otherwise,
nobody really can survive it.
When I'm a startup founder,
I wake up every morning. I decide,
"This is the experiment
that I'm going to do today."
At the end of the day,
this experiment will fail
and the next morning,
I have to wake up with the same
attitude that I am going to make
experiment number two.
And this experiment
may fail as well
this is a startup life
and it's crucial
for you to survive this kind of
trial and error routine.
And being optimistic
is a must have.
How do you then delegate
that happiness
and optimism to the people
that work under you as a CTO,
because you're not necessarily the
one who's writing all the code,
and a lot of the times, you have
to also put on this product
tag and you have to bring
a lot of that down, you know,
top-down for the team.
What are some of the ways
that you do that?
Great question.
So, you really need
to split your tough --
your stories into
like small chunks, small tasks.
And this actually helps
to deliver faster
and make frequent delivers
actually helps the team
move forward.
Right.
This type of development
mindset actually helps a lot
because, let's say,
if you decide on building
a product with a huge amount
of features and a big list
of requirements on it's own,
nobody really can deliver it,
but if you just split it
into small chunks of requirements,
and every time you build
something, you deliver it,
you test it immediately,
you get the impact, and so on.
- This actually helps
- Definitely.
people who works with you
move forward
and see the real impact.
And every line of code
should have  an impact.
If the line --
Nobody writes code just to like --
as beautiful code.
It really doesn't matter like seriously.
- Right.
- Sometimes,
you just have to realize
real people actually enjoy
having this situation.
It doesn't matter if you work
on a client right now or you're
building some back office.
Just put on your hand
the same person
and try to do the same process.
_ It doesn't --
- Definitely.
make you happy,
just using this smaller project.
It's something that I always
request from developers.
Just try to use it yourself.
They will actually use it,
like literally.
You don't need a designer, you
don't need a user experience guy.
And so, just be the user yourself.
Definitely, definitely.
So we have to --
our 20 minutes is coming up,
but I'd like to ask you
the final question.
And it's putting you
a little bit on the spot.
But what are three words
that you would best
describe you as?
I already know
at least one of them.
But what are the three that you
would best describe yourself as?
Optimist is one of those.
I like helping people
is the second one,
and I'm entrepreneur,
like traveling and move forward.
That's really, really great.
David, thank you very, very much.
- Thank you.
- It was great.
- Great. Take care.
- Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. It was wonderful, really.
Thank you.